welcome back to the Hillsdale College
Constitution Town Hall we're thrilled to
be able now to in our second
presentation move on to a most important
topic and that's the question of what
exactly is the Constitution what does it
stand for what are the how are we to
understand it joining us today is dr.
Matt Spaulding to introduce him is a
Hillsdale College student nicholas
pleasure is in washington now
hills dales campus is in Hillsdale
Michigan a small community of about
8,000 people the Washington Hillsdale
internship program our whip for short
has for 35 years
sent Hillsdale College students to the
nation's capital there they're kept
really busy and what they do is they
intern full-time they take a couple of
classes one in public policy the other
in American national security studies
and they do a bunch of fun things then
as a group and those things include
going to Gettysburg getting a staff ride
they're learning about that battle they
go to Frederick Douglass's a historic
home he lived in Washington DC for the
last 17 years of his life and they do a
bunch of other things that really build
upon the things that they're learning in
the classroom the things that they've
learned on hills dales campus and the
things that they're doing every day
Nick's internship is with Illinois
congressman Peter Roskam and he's going
to introduce Matt Spaulding Nicholas
Thank You dr. Bob Oh I'm Nick pleasure
and I have the pleasure of introducing
dr. Matt Spaulding he is the director of
the be Kenneth Simon Center for American
Studies at the Heritage Foundation where
he is also a project leader of the first
principles initiative the mission of the
Center for American Studies is to teach
policymakers and political leaders about
the principles of our political
tradition and to explain the continued
relevance and application of those
principles in the 21st century he is
also an adjunct fellow with a Kirby
Center dr. Spaulding earned his BA from
Claremont McKenna College and as a PhD
he earned his PhD in government at the
Claremont Graduate School he has also
taught at Hillsdale College Claremont
McKenna the Catholic University of
America and George Mason University he
is the author and editor of several
books including we still hold these
truths rediscovering our principles and
also reclaiming our future the heritage
guide to the Constitution the founders
Almanac and Patriot sage George
Washington and the American political
tradition he is also a frequent guest on
the Fox News Channel please join me in
welcoming dr. Spaulding as he speaks on
the topic
the founders Constitution
thanks Nick good morning everybody how
are you doing it's great to be with you
especially since I get to talk about a
great topic the United States
Constitution about I start my
conversation with you this morning
actually in Rome in particular the
building that the Romans built their
temple called the Pantheon which perhaps
who have been there it's one of their
greatest structures of the ancient world
was built so the Romans could have a
place to keep their conquered gods the
flags and signs of khakhra nations
statues of their Caesars statues of
their military heroes but here we are
near Washington DC you've been there
before as well I'm sure we have our own
Pantheon many of our buildings in
Washington designed after ancient Greek
temples and Roman temples but one of
those is the National Archives building
National Archives building on the
outside looks like you know Greek
columns virtually designed to be a model
of the Roman pantheon interestingly
enough but when you go into the National
Archives building you don't see statues
of our military heroes you don't see the
signs and the of our military victories
you don't see the things we've conquered
what you see instead is a small altar if
you will and inside that under glass
some very faded hard to read parchment
papers and on those papers are a few
words
you see documents and then a nutshell
tells you the importance of where we
place those things because those two
documents the Declaration Independence
in the United States Constitution are
the two greatest statements of freedom
written by the hand of man in world
history and we must understand that the
Constitution self is a remarkable
document it's only about fifty four
hundred words
if it's on four pieces of that parchment
it's much shorter than virtually every
piece of legislation are most piece of
legislation today written by the United
States Congress it's the culmination of
Western political thought all the great
ideas of the past the developed and
Western civilization lead to this
document it is the architecture if you
will of all our liberties the great
rights in our Declaration are secured
through this document called the United
States Constitution but as well it's
important to keep in mind that this the
same piece of parchment paper is a
target and has been a target for some
time the Constitution is pointed to by
every country in the world all of those
people yearning to be free point to
these documents and uphold our
Constitution but the critics of freedom
don't like the Constitution abroad but
also at home the progressives don't like
the Constitution many that want to get
around the Constitution many politicians
presidents judges they see the
Constitution as a barrier it's in their
way because the Constitution is a bridle
for what they want to accomplish the
progress is wanting to get around so
much they're going to invent something
called the living Constitution but
that's very different from that piece of
parchment you see in the National
Archives today unfortunately in many
ways people say the Constitution doesn't
matter anymore when it comes up in
debate when it come to debate in the
United States Congress when prominent
members of the legislature those in line
to be present United States are asked
about the Constitution and the
constitutionality of particular piece of
legislation and they say it's not a
serious question
but more and more Americans are not
agreeing with that sentiment and they
know the importance of that document
because everything about our country not
just our legal system but the way we
constitute ourselves as a people looks
back to that old faded document so what
I want you to try today is is start us
on the path of rediscovering it now the
that period that led up to the American
Revolution from the end of the French
renewing war up to the Declaration of
Independence that long period right
remember these long train of abuse or
patience in the Declaration now the
Americans were forced to think through
some things they hadn't thought about
before right they had been pretty happy
columns for a long time but now they had
to do some serious thinking we see that
coming out and declaration independence
they had to think about the real source
of their rights where are those sources
for those rights to be found there to be
found in natural rights where does
government get its legitimacy the
consent of the governed we have those
things in the Declaration but now the
question is how do we secure those
rights and how do we create a government
that actually is based on consent which
points us towards another principle that
is everywhere in the Constitution it's
everywhere in our system but it's very
rarely stated and it's called the rule
of law which in many ways is the
greatest accomplishment of Western
constitutional thought the idea of the
rule of law now that's an idea that goes
back to classical antiquity you see it
in Aristotle's distinction about regimes
you see it in Cicero and other political
philosophers we see it in Western
thought in British history starting and
taking off the time of something called
Magna Carta 1215 you recall it right
King John gets cornered by his barons
and he's got to give away a little bit
of power but the most famous the most
American statement of the rule of law is
very simple it's in the masses who's its
constitution of 1780
John Adams he creates this Constitution
he says so that we can have a government
of laws not of men that's what the rule
of law really means the government of
law as opposed to a government of men
which is say arbitrary despotic
tyrannical at the whim and will of
somebody else this concept the rule law
means many things and for the Americans
it started to flesh out for them as they
thought these things sir one thing it
meant is this idea of due process a word
that comes up in our Constitution but a
very old concept what is the law
guarantee you it guarantees you the
process to which you are do as a citizen
who has an equal standing and rights
also taught them that no one is above
the law
no one's below it everyone deserves
protection but no one's above it you
can't ignore it as well there are also
certain things inherent in the rule of
law that you can't overlook certain
principles in the law itself inherent in
the very idea of it ex post facto law
comes up in our Constitution later as
well an ancient concept you can't make
something illegal after the fact you
can't do something today and tomorrow
they pass a law against it and make you
a criminal
but the other thing that it made them
think of and force me think about is
what was the relationship of this rule
of law to those who make the law because
the rule of law implies that there is
something above those who make it in the
first place there's something higher
there's something more fundamental and
this raised in their mind this idea of a
constitution again not a new concept
Aristotle talks about this as well Magna
Carta implied a constitution something
you've going to write down as well but
once you have this idea of equal rights
it becomes much more important to get it
right and you see the British they
didn't get it right they have something
called the Glorious Revolution which was
pretty good but they didn't do it
because what they didn't have was a
written constitution
we take this for granted we have a
written constitution we assume that's
what it means
the British had no such thing and the
Americans having gone through this
experience with the British and
sensitive on writing it down very simple
idea writing it down in a way that puts
the rules of the rule of law the process
on paper so that we could all read it so
that you could read it and I could read
it citizens could read it and understand
it because we have the rights and you
don't they weren't a fundamental
document that wrote it down in simple
language for citizens to secure those
rights for themselves so they could
govern themselves and this document that
describes how all that works now let's
look at it let's actually look at the
thing in our little and our
constitutions every citizen in this
country should have it and be what they
carry with it all the time it's a very
simple document remember it's only five
thousand four hundred words you can't
read legislation that that's it that's
short after the preamble which is this
wonderful glorious statement about its
objectives some of them have to a safety
some have to do with how we're going to
take care of ourselves and then the
others point to the future securing the
blessings of liberty the document has
virtually everything to do with merely
securing and laying out powers
procedures institutions all those boring
things that most people don't like to
study but that's precisely what this
document is supposed to do right the
declaration has stated what our rights
are these grand ideas of rights grounded
in nature the Constitution is about
powers powers it creates three branches
of government branches of government are
then described in sections and clauses
after that the three branches of
government follow importantly the first
is is the most democratic then less and
less
there's a purpose that the law making is
the rules law is the primary branch
although they're all equal the key thing
and understanding how the Constitution
operates is to look at the beginning of
each one of the first three articles
which lay out those branches that begin
with something called a vesting clause
you see our Constitution something of
delegated powers the people who are
sovereign possess the right delegate
power to the federal government in the
form of these vesting clauses in vest
power it does invest power to the
federal government inherently invest
power to individual branches the
legislature the executive and the
judiciary the three vesting clauses are
different the legislative vesting clause
vest lates the powers herein granted
very important and then it lists some
article one section eight the famous
article one section eight it lists about
sixteen or so different powers or things
that Congress can do in its lawmaking
Authority which was the most important
thing they had wanted to control which
is why they also divide it in half two
houses of Congress but those clauses in
those sections enumerate the powers that
Congress has to make laws very simple
and by that authority of a vesting power
into that branch it's implied but not
state as well that you cannot meaning
Congress person has that power delegated
to them can't go around giving it to
somebody else
it's the legislative power the president
has the executive power you can't give
it in exchange it keep that in mind
because this is gonna become a bigger
issue as we as we go forward delegating
power willy-nilly to other people
article 1 makes it very clear the
government's powers are limited to those
things enumerated now there is something
called the Necessary and Proper Clause
which says that you can also legislate
things that are necessary and proper
discordant phrase not open-ended to
carry out these powers right that's also
a source of great debate article 2 the
executive power vests the executive
power in the president
now this is a little bit more
interesting more difficult it's not
power they get from the legislature it's
their own power it's called the
executive power and it's vested in that
person that's important because there's
only one person in the United States who
takes a specific oath in the
Constitution to defend the Constitution
and his commander-in-chief
there's something about especially
foreign policy demands that type of
authority vested in one person but this
erases all these questions which we like
to debate a lot about the nature of
executive power but it's the job of the
president to faithfully execute the laws
going back to the rule of law an article
3 which is the shortest interesting ly
enough have assets Authority and supreme
court and other courts that Congress may
choose to make now this is interesting
as well because all of the judicial
power is vested in the courts but it's
only the judicial power they don't have
the lawmaking power they don't have the
executive power they have the judicial
power which to say they can make
decisions based on cases and contours
that come before them in exercising
their judicial role other articles then
after that start talk about how this
plan is going to operate right the
fourth article talks about the relations
with the states and the federal
government very important the fifth
article talks about how we're going to
amend this document we're gonna change
it not by interpretation but by a
legitimate process of amendment and the
seventh talks about how it's gonna be
ratified and oh by the way dates it in
the year of our Lord and the year of the
Declaration the Bill of Rights then is
added later originally opposed to bill
rights because they argued that the
Constitution self is a Bill of Rights
because it limits government fundamental
question one point but they decided they
needed to get it through in order to get
the current constitution passes they
wrote a bill of rights which were
restrictions on the federal government
the first has to do with substantive
rights religious liberty ma'am man you
monumental accomplishment of the
founding
religion speech press assembly petition
ii protection of one's ability to obsess
firearms right crucial right to keep and
bear arms third through a is mostly
procedural it's about criminal law right
the things you have to protect yourself
against being wrongly dealt with by the
government and the ninth and tenth
really states in very short order the
meaning of the Constitution itself all
powers that aren't delegated or reserved
to the states and to the people there
are three very important additional
things that aren't spoken about in the
Constitution that I wanna mention very
briefly what are called auxilary powers
or auxilary precautions operational
things that don't get stated starts
quietly important but the founders
thought they were extremely important
one is representation by default we have
a representative form of government the
founders thought this was very important
because it filters the passions right
through the proper process of
representation very important to slow
things down they create a republic not a
democracy their republic they were in
deliberation and thoughtful legislation
secondly this concept of the separation
of powers which we've all heard before
in our civics courses write checks and
balances they want to take these powers
not only write it down in the
constitution but separate them break
them apart give them to this to this
into this and then even on top of that
they were so concerned about the nature
of power and politics that they made
them fight against each other
intentionally so the legislature keeps
eye on the executive and the executive
keeps an eye by pointing the court the
court keeps an eye on the legislature
it's a brilliant plan why because of
this question of faction and passions in
man at once political power
that's ardent Federalist ten right the
way you recognize that's a fact of human
nature but the way we're going to deal
with that is we're gonna make them fight
against each other right
we don't want it make it easy we're
gonna make them squabble and when they
squabble what are they gonna squabble
over their powers and what are they
gonna protect because they're scrubbing
of their powers the Constitution
right it's quite thoughtful quite
brilliant and the third third thing they
were it was important to add is the
question of federalism again sorry all
there
perhaps not state as squarely as we
might like especially nowadays but but
it's the inherent deep meaning of this
document which is there's the division
between the federal government and the
state governments certain things a
delegate to the federal government this
is in Federalist 45 in your readings
certain things delegate to the federal
government national security some things
about the economy they're to do them
right and have the powers to do it
everything else almost all the things
that deal with our day-to-day lives are
to be reserved to the states to the
state constitutions let me conclude by
destroying distinction to the principles
government and the actual practices of
government Madison for one and others
made of this distinction very
importantly and said there were two
different compacts behind our government
was established one is a compact about
principles the declaration how we as a
people what are the fundamental
principles on which we're going to
organize your society but the other is
an I is a compact about how we're going
to actually form the government how
we're going to structurally organizing
it organize it and for the families this
is crucially important crucially
important all the things we think are
boring nowadays they thought were the
essential qualities to preserve liberty
because merely having an abstract class
abstract statement of Liberty of
declaring of rights is not sufficient
you must ever be mindful of how it
actually works because if you are not
you will lose control of it because
sometimes the passions to do things if
you're not wary of how power is
accumulating can lead to something much
much worse this is the essential meaning
of Tocqueville famous warning of the
possibility of a new form of despotism
when you take a deep and powerful
passion to make everything equal
the Galit arianism and you take this
power of government to make things equal
and you continually centralize it and
centralize it he says this might form of
a new create a new form of despotism in
which government is the shepherd and the
people are the Sheep he warned about
this a long time ago the problem is that
we've shifted away from constitutional
government to something else
slowly the rule by experts in
bureaucrats and others who are ruling us
rather than us governing ourselves that
I think is the real question here the
Constitution at the end of the day is
not merely a legal document it is a
document by which we govern ourselves
and we must be the ones to reclaim it
I'm often asked where I speak to
students and go on lectures how can we
make that argument we are so far beyond
our Constitution it's an old document
it's faded you can't read it it's merely
a piece of paper it was so long ago but
think about that for a moment it's not
that long ago we're not going back to
Magna Carta we're just going back a few
generations I was born during the Great
Society my father was born during the
New Deal
when he was young the great justice in
the court was Oliver Wendell Holmes
follower the Holmes fought in civil war
had met Lincoln when Lincoln was a boy
the present was John Quincy Adams and
when John Quincy Adams was a boy he
heard the fire the gunfire at the Battle
of Bunker Hill our founding is not that
far away from us it is still within our
reach we must rediscover it
we must reclaim it thank you and we have
time for questions we do have lots of
time for questions in velasca our studio
audience again to come to the two
microphones we are going to start with
an online question this comes from James
from Cleveland Ohio isn't giving all
Americans access to affordable
healthcare conducive to the general
welfare why shouldn't the federal
government be a part of this especially
if it has the power to help its citizens
there's a great question in this this
question of health care is a wonderful
way to think through was a prank man or
how the Constitution ought to operate
inform how we think about things today
it shows you how far we've gone there's
a matter of merely debate is mostly
about here's what we want to do how do
we get there what's what clause do we
hang it on the two closets most I'm used
to to look to to justify a health care
on behalf of the federal government or
the Commerce Clause and the general the
so-called general welfare clause we'd
claims both the the general welfare
Clause is actually a clause that has to
do with taxation right the notion that
the federal government has the power to
bring about the general welfare is
incorrect it simply is not there the
Commerce Clause which is the other one
is often pointed to has to do with the
federal government having the power to
regulate interstate commerce a very
specific thing
falcomon does not have the power to
generally regulate commerce but setting
all that side for a moment the
healthcare argument is actually not
argued for on the basis of Commerce per
se let me give you a particular example
the most unconstitutional aspect of the
healthcare leaders
has to have something called the
individual mandate which is say that the
federal government is going to mandate
that every individual by health care
insurance which is say or another way
the federal government is going to
mandate regulate use its constitutional
power to require each individual whether
they choose to do so or not to enter a
contract they base that on the Commerce
Clause or the general welfare clause if
the Commerce Clause can be read to say
that the federal government has the
power to regulate you who choose to do
nothing right by choosing to not buy
health care you are choosing in and not
to do something it's an inactivity the
federal gonna have the power to regulate
inactivity here with me the federal
government and that Commerce Clause is
literally unlimited that as far as I can
see there's an irrational argument
all right that's backwards thinking
here's what I want to do how do I get
there same with this phrase general
welfare yes the general welfare is a
good thing the federal grant does
certain things to help the general
welfare creates a framework of law right
it makes sure we have a stable economy
it coins money to to to under a to to
strengthen our economy it protects
property rights right it does things for
the general welfare very much so but
that does not give the federal
government power to do things the
Constitution is about powers the answer
to the question about health care has to
do with states states let them
experiment let them do different things
through their laboratories of democracy
this is a primary example I think health
care where the aim of the Constitution
has gone wrong radically wrong
our second question then comes for our
studio audience my name is Christine and
I live in Virginia Beach right now
I've actually I went to Hillsdale and I
wrote a paper my senior year and I it
was on this question but I still kind of
wrestle with the issue so I'll pose it
to you and see what you have to say I
wrestle with the issue of whether the
Bill of Rights was a good or a bad idea
for the Constitution because the
Constitution is based on the natural
rights theory of law and the negative
rights theory and the Bill of Rights is
kind of based on the British monarch
achill form of government and you know
you carve out rights from that sovereign
entity but as Americans we don't believe
that's where our rights we don't carve
out rights they're ours to begin with so
the Bill of Rights in essence fused the
idea of positive law to our constitute
excuse me our Constitution a negative
law document and now when citizens quote
are their rights they say well that
rights in the First Amendment or you
know they have they feel like they have
to quote where their right comes from
instead of where the government's power
comes from to take it away which you
articulated it it's like article 1
section 8 lists the powers that that the
legislature has so nowadays though it
seems prudent that the rights are listed
considering how much the federal
government has expanded but my question
is how do we fix our positive rights
view of government and in the future
guard against it when the idea is fused
into our Constitution how much time do
we have
he's been a whole semester and this
question is I didn't you wrote of course
the answer here is actually yes and no
so that's we're never to have it both
ways which is to say that the argument
against the Bill of Rights which is a
very strong argument is that the
Constitution if you remember the
Constitution really about powers
delegated the concepts by limiting those
powers is itself a bill of rights by
radically limiting those powers but the
anti-federalists one in the Bill of Bill
of Rights because most states had Bill
of Rights and the state level that's a
good thing right because state
constitutions work differently they
wanted a bill of rights and Madison
being smart guy that he was he was a
smart guy we got to write a bill of
rights but what he did is he's all right
it myself
and so what he rose a bill of rights
applicable to the Federal Constitution
right it's what states rights but it
states them in a way that limits federal
powers so the Bill of Rights itself I
think works fine it's not the problem
the problem with the Bill of Rights
itself the problem is what the Bill of
Rights has been used to accomplish
through incorporation the courts have
said it applies to the states but also
even more problematic how those rights
have been interpreted by courts to
expand powers as the Bill of Rights has
come exactly the opposite where it's
intended to be which is rather than
limiting federal power is from an
expansion of federal power to the
detriment of state local authority and
to the to the detriment of Liberty
simply now the advantage we have this is
of actually erasing point you raise is
that given where we are today however
what do we look to to protect ourselves
oftentimes it's the Bill of Rights what
we need to be doing is using the bill
that the claims in the Bill of Rights
the pieces of bill rights we want to to
press cases about property rights
breaking our freedom of speech
protecting our religious liberty but
when I do those in a way that force us
to look to the rest of the Constitution
the problem today is that most people
when you ask me the constant they think
it merely means the Bill of Rights and
that is a very problematic misnomer
that's what the courts think today to us
right they want spend most time talking
about the Bill of Rights we need to get
back to this the use the Bill of Rights
to protect those rights but the rights
were protected in the Constitution
itself so all these years later I'm
actually kind of happy with Bill of
Rights but it still does not should not
prevent us and blind us to getting back
to the document itself and the serious
way in which our system of federal
powers limited state powers local
authority broad kind of notions of self
governing Liberty need to operate I
think we need to move in that direction
our next question comes from a
participant in Erie Pennsylvania and
Murray asks we've heard a lot about
czars recently in the national
government presidents including the
current one have appointed czars our
czars constitutional
talk about it great a great opening you
know the best part of this this is our
question comes is actually the notional
calling mizar's is this not just or are
as many people pointed out you know
they're more czars in the fellowman now
than the Romanovs appointed ahead in 300
years of russian history there's a
certain messiness in this is our
question and I want to broaden it a
little bit to make you think about it a
little bit differently which to say that
in many ways it's not the issue of the
particulars or whether one is someone
who is or is not a czar as completely
arbitrary it's not actually in their
title my guess is they're a lot more
czars out there than we know about um
the problem is what's going on here and
as Congress has delegated all of its
power
Moses power a lot of its legislative
power to these bureaucrats right and
these bureaucrats are right in laws
that's essentially what they're doing
those are laws and the question is how
is a president who has a constitutional
oath to execute the law going to control
it so what is he gonna do
he will use his existing officers that
hmm have to report to whom the Congress
or he's ain't trying to go around the
system and he appoints these people who
are now called czars they report to him
personally to try to carry out his
agenda so in a certain sense it actually
makes a lot of sense if you accept where
we are today which is in this terrible
bureaucratic mind-boggling intricate
mess in some cases as our it is
unconstitutional if czar is an
individual who is doing something they
have not been confirmed by the Senate
and they're operating away that
essentially conducting and carrying out
law right outside of the structure that
Congress has passed right that raises a
constitutional problem but the larger
constitutes from I think is a more
important one
which is that the Czar's some of whom
have been confirmed by the senate right
now are largely operating out operating
outside of the constitutional structure
itself because congress by passing these
messy messy messy laws essentially have
allowed these individuals and their
minions to do what is their
constitutional responsibility which is
to pass the law they've passed the buck
this opening and this current debate
about czars should be used as a wedge to
break open a much larger debate about
the nature of how government operates
today that is the true constitutional
problem we have another online question
from Jill in Lubbock Texas
today's citizens and politicians alike
defer questions of interpretation of the
Constitution to the Supreme Court what
role should the executive and
legislative branches play in
constitutional interpretation who or
what is the ultimate ultimate arbiter of
the Constitution's meaning that's
another that's another great question
one of the key misnomers today widely
believed by students especially widely
taught in law schools generally assumed
is that the ultimate arbiter the decider
on constitutional questions is Supreme
Court that is wrong on so many levels
it's hard to know where to start but
again go back to your structure the
Constitution creates three branches of
government each branch takes the same
oath of office to defend the cold
Constitution which is say that
legislature has the same requirement
moral requirement to uphold what they
believe the Constitution means to
exercise their powers to defend their
powers as the executive and the courts
that's why the founders clearly laid it
out to be um having said that the nature
of the rule of law and the judicial
power I believe and the founders which
is Hamilton others who wrote about it
implies something called judicial review
in a case or contradict constitutional
powers to take that piece of law and the
Constitution side by side way them think
about it and take the site of the
Constitution that implies judicial
review in the cases and controversies
that come before them ie the legislative
judicial process but there's a limit to
that there's always been a limit that
until quite recently the court can't go
about really nearly saying the
Constitution means what ever the heck
they want it to me and if they do the
legislature and the executive who have
taken an oath to uphold the Constitution
have an obligation to challenge them by
using their legitimate powers to pass
other legislation to to restrict the
courts authority to create other courts
to strip the court of its powers they
can stop paying their wages right the
executive can appoint different judges
this is precisely with what was intended
at the end of the day the only final
arbiter of what the Constitution means
are the people of the United States so
the system is designed to allow these
things to percolate up through a
judicial system come up in a case or
controversy a court makes a decision
they take the cite the case they decide
applies to the people in the case it can
set a little of a precedent kind of
tells us how this court might decide in
the future but it's not written in stone
by no means courts over change their
minds all the time but if the
legislation in an executive disagree
they can go on and do other things
you got a crisis one of the greatest
crises of course comes up with President
Lincoln and he said this case the famous
Dred Scott case doesn't applies to the
particular 's for Dred Scott but doesn't
apply to everybody else
it's not settled the question was the
questions ultimately settled in another
way and the regular process the way it
should work is it settled through the
legislative the executive the judicial
fighting about it and ultimately through
elections elections when the people
decide and send people to Washington
with a different understanding or the
same understanding and that still
doesn't work what do you do you amend
the Constitution that's the way it's
supposed to work the process is still
there to do that the problem is that we
have too often assumed and allowed this
understanding to become so settled that
presidents and legislatures are no
longer willing to even question that
a recent president not the current one
but the previous one signed legislation
that he thought maybe might be
unconstitutional and he said in his
signing statement it may be
unconstitutional but I'll let the courts
decide that that is a terrible deep not
only violation is conscious
responsibility but I think fundamental
misunderstands how our system ought to
work in in deciding these questions we
have time for one more question that
will come from our audience in person
here please hi dr. Spaulding I'm Linda
Kendal from Fairfax station
my question is today we have more than
300 agencies that regulate our lives
that in my view are usurping the role
that is mandated by the Constitution to
be done by Congress do you see any path
for reversal of this and could you offer
any pragmatic advice to achieve it thank
you
Gregg great question as well I mean I
believe the greatest revolution of the
20th century and the 20th century seen a
lot of revolutions is the shift from
constitutional government to what we
might call bureaucratic government
in the extent to which most lawmaking
and ruling is done by a process to which
we have given not given our consent that
is the modern problem we don't even know
how many these agencies are out there
doing these things right health care
bill is a perfect example we didn't know
how it operated we still don't know how
it operates we don't know about how many
and they're just hundreds of commissions
in it what are they doing how do you
push back from that is a much more
difficult problem it's going to take
some time the first step however is to
understand and firmly come to the
commitment that that is not how our
system operates and we assert that she
says a footnote I think that's what's
happening right now would you say
politics changes these things the first
thing we must do is to reclaim our
Constitution through the political
branches of government right that's
exactly how Madison those and the boys
set it out to work right you you get
that moving and but then Congress has
got to stop delegating its power to
these people but the only way Congress
and skaars stop delegating the power
because they can't do all the things
they want to do is to not do some of
these things simple they can't run
healthcare themselves they've got to
delegate it so if you don't want it
these things delegate to these people
you don't elect who you don't know when
we're gonna make decisions very private
decisions in the most about most
intimate questions about your life if
you want that to happen you've got to
get Congress to stop doing these things
it's a political question in the case of
health care and almost everything else
is a radical decentralization of
authority from Washington back to the
States
we've got to start governing ourselves
again I mean these things are being very
hard the actual ways of doing it at what
point do you challenge what agency do
you
bringing a constitutional challenge to
try to actually cut off funds how that's
going to operate is me very difficult
and you have to let politics determine